I know you recommend paying for things
with cash or a debit card but how do you
feel about digital payment options like
Apple pay zel and venmo it's easy for me
to just pay with my phone but it almost
feels like play money at this point
should I stay with what's convenient but
a little harder for me to track with
digital payment or what's more
cumbersome and takes more time to deal
with with pulling our cash and splitting
everything up feels like I can't win
either way I do see that it's easier to
spend it's even more frictionless I mean
Apple pay's tagline is cashless made
effortless they know that they'll get
you to spend more if you can just double
tap on your phone and hold it near your
reader you don't even need to pull the
card out anymore but when it comes to
digital payments here's my take if you
are doing a zerob based budget and you
are aware of what you're spending and
you've allocated all of that it's okay
if you do Apple pay instead of pulling
out your debit card